so I tried shooting this intro live
several times but each time I miserably
failed so let me start again
this is an interview show called coffee
with where I have interesting
conversations over coffee with youtubers
or anyone that's interesting this is the
first episode where I interview the
amazing wheels coder but before we get
to who he is and start the show I want
to tell you why I created coffee with
now that I finished the interview and
have had time to collect my thoughts if
you don't know me I run coffee break a
video essay channel where I break down
big ideas but besides being a creator
myself I'm also a really big fan of
other youtubers that break down big
ideas I love when someone can teach
complex ideas and are on the cutting
edge of using media to do so and I want
to talk with some of these people
discuss their ideas inspirations and
origins usually these people are behind
a curtain and professionalism in their
videos but if you strip that away and
just talk with them you find it there
unexpectedly witty or funny or kind and
I want to show that over a cup of coffee
plus it's a great excuse to go meet and
talk to these amazing educators
entertainers thinkers drinkers and maybe
one day Steven Pinker's that's kind of
that one the last one's kind of down the
road but yeah that's the thesis of the
show so now that you're caught up to
speed let me just say this will be
available as a podcast as a video
interview on YouTube and highlight
should also be going up soon and
especially on these first few episodes
I'm very interested in feedback so after
watching the show
leave your comments of what you thought
and maybe some questions you'd like to
hear in the future for our first guest
we have wills coder he makes videos on
culture irony post-modernism philosophy
the brain and even mr. Rogers in this
interview we talk about what it means to
be a video essayist we talk philosophy
the age of distraction we live in wills
gratitude notes he writes every morning
and more it's a little slow going at
first but I think we hit our stride
toward the middle and some really cool
stuff comes out of the conversations for
those of you who are watching this I did
mess up the camera
on wills face so he's a little bit out
of frame for the first half until I
realized my mistake and we kind of fix
it so my apologies for that but let's
not get ahead of ourselves
grab a cup of coffee grab a cozy couch
here's me find in New York City and
here's what we talked about ready sure
let's do it all right sorry
welcome to the first edition of coffee
width
where we interview interesting creators
the were interesting creation oh man I
hate doing stuff like what which is why
I created this show god conquer those
fears yeah yeah yeah so thanks for
coming on today we're drinking out of
the scooter mugs get your get yourself
one on his patreon and let's get into it
so this is a question that I always
wanted to ask a fellow video at essayist
how do you describe what you do that's
ahead like if someone said like what's
your John written they don't know
anything about video essays what do you
say I'm definitely still working on this
one I think it's really hard to describe
exactly what video essays are sure there
have been many of fights on the internet
I think about defining what a video
essay is I personally define it very
widely but when I like let's say I'm not
dinner with people that I don't know and
they're like oh what do you do and then
they ask what our video essays I think
the way I describe it is simply I write
an essay and I try to animate that essay
yeah okay and that is literally yet I
don't try and add any bells and whistles
to it because that's really the process
that I do I write an essay and then I
spend an exorbitant amount of time
figuring out how to animate that essay
right that's literally it I've tried
like stories about ideas I've
like many documentaries before but I
have yet to come up with a really good
yeah video essays tend to follow a a
format that can mold in any way that you
want it has to have a you know thesis
and it has to have a conclusion but
pretty much any but like in between
there like in a lot of my videos I start
with sort of a in the in my most recent
video I talk about how I have this
problem all the time about you know I
can't retain information that I want to
retain and that's just sort of starting
with like hey like this is an opinion
piece I have this problem and then from
there I could jump into how to fix that
I think you could also not do that and
just start with how to fix that you know
and you can kind of do it any way you
really want that's how I said how I look
at it too so with how broad you can how
broadly you can think about video essays
what do you think about the tendency to
focus on film I think if you look at
most video essays they tend to focus
specifically on film film analysis which
is it makes sense in the medium because
before analyzing film is very difficult
right and now you can just show it on
screen and like point out all the
different things totally but is that a
limiting way to think about it yes but
it also makes sense so it would it's
almost like essays were really great to
analyze certain things in the past
textually and movies and film never they
never had that and now they have that
right which is huge because if you want
to explain how a visual medium works you
should probably use a visual medium yeah
but I do think it is limiting because I
think video essays encompass quite
literally anything that you want to talk
about any explanatory thing any opinion
thing I mean anything that you can write
say about should be able to become a
video I think Tony Zhu when he started
every frame of painting sort of cause
don't you say his name is you I'm not
sure I thought is that I don't know Joe
maybe the king the the King yeah you
know the guy who kind of started at all
yeah he obviously started with film and
then that cascaded and cut you know
everybody else started to do that as
well right and I think that's great I
think there's an infinite number of
perspectives that people can come at
film and TV with I do think there
remains a void in audio-visual content
that is not about film and TV and that's
still just kind of starting up I think
Vox does it I was yeah they're sort of
the most at least in my mind them and
the nerdwriter we're the first ones to
sort of like push video sa content that
wasn't strictly film and television yeah
yeah I I would even argue that like
animated explainers are falling into a
video essay category like in a nutshell
is definitely in my mind video essay
it's just it gets put in the animated
explainer category because that's kind
of what it is but it can fit in the
absolutely this is a video essay
category you know what I mean
yep I'm becoming totally aware of how
much I say the same words there's not
like I'm like right right oh right
hmm yes mm-hmm I you mean I think when
you listen to a lot of podcasts yeah you
also become hyper aware of the people
who do it yeah you're like this person
is someone who has to say mm-hmm yes
right after like the thing and then
other people will just until the person
ends their thing and that they write
again let me cut in yeah no actually I
think for audio it's probably better to
just wait I don't know let me check it's
all about
learning to see what works you know
unless you do it a bunch you have no
idea
so something something that I find
really interesting about whenever I
looked at your channel for the first
time I you are not tied to a an upload
schedule nearly at all as much as I wish
I was yeah I'm I think of my own like
uploads is rather sporadic but I get
very anxious when I haven't uploaded in
a while and I was just wondering how do
you think about upload schedule and all
that kind of stuff because you seem to
be somebody who you're so much more
concerned with the product being done
then you I think even in your
description you're like videos come out
when they're little bit of a middle
finger to be I was like you guys can't
wait yeah well videos come out when
they're done because I think there is a
lot to be said about pressuring yourself
to meet a deadline in my experience even
when I put a deadline on a video essay I
without a doubt fly right past that
deadline because it's not done yeah and
I think it's much more important that
the product is high quality and teaches
well and you know is free of flaws I
have a perfectionist problem obviously
it takes me like three months to release
some videos so I think I have yet to
find the happy medium which is you know
getting it as good as you can but also
releasing more content I'm in between
I'm trying to get in between right now
I'm all the way at like it has to be
totally totally done right to the
perfect image that I have I'll get over
it eventually and to be clear with like
the audience because sometimes I think
if you don't appear for three months
they can think that I
you're like doing you're working or you
doing whatever to be clear what's your
work schedule like when you do that
because there's sporadic upload so
sometimes people can think oh he's
working it's the same amount of hours to
complete each video but he just was busy
during this with time or not busy
yes I'm sure working the hours that I
put into videos varies so for example I
have a video about satire the cartoons
and satire right that video probably
took me 60 hours in total right but then
another video for example the I am a
strange loop video took me three months
of working pretty much every day for an
extended for a full day yeah like a full
day of work so it depends on the topic
of the video is the first part you know
if I were to talk about Star Wars I
could just take Star Wars use the
pre-existing footage from Star Wars and
talk over it some topics if you're
making original animation can take much
longer because you have to make every
second new so the time varies but for me
I have you know certain obligations that
I do throughout the week but for the
most part I am in here editing videos
perfect yeah
what is your so when you have an idea
let's start with idea capture let's try
to go through the creative process a
little bit what's your idea capture you
have like a note on your iPhone what do
you do I do have an idea capture which
is an Excel document I just basically
fill it with ideas and then I'll color
code it in terms of priorities so it'll
be like green is this needs to happen
sooner yellow is like after green and
then red is like I'm kind of interested
in that but it's kind of on the back
burner that's how I organize my ideas in
terms of idea capture and
and how that then becomes a video is
very much like I've been thinking about
this constantly for the last you know a
couple months and now I want to release
that thought yeah you like all those
knots into something hopefully helpful
to people and that can come from reading
a couple different books and seeing how
different ideas connect or reading
articles or just seeing the flow of
ideas on the internet and deciding if
it's something that I should produce but
for the most part it's like I've been
thinking about this constantly and I
think it's worthwhile to put it into
words right yeah so have you ever so
have you had ideas not pan out like I've
I've had many a time where I start the
research process and either one of my
intuitions was wrong or like something
that I thought maybe was supported in
the data was not supported in the data
something that was a you know kind of
part of what made it interesting kind of
fell through or wasn't as interesting as
I thought has that ever happened to you
it's never happened
just because before I even start it I
know like all the surrounding ideas
before I start writing it I'm like I
have the outline here and I know that
this is how I want it to flow I think
more likely and this has happened is
I'll have an idea and then I realized
the scope is just like gonna make me go
crazy and I can't do it well like what
like what you got you got one you can
think of I wanted to do something about
the internet and how there's this theory
it's called the social intuitionist
theory and how it binds us into tribes
on the internet and just how that theory
interacts strangely with like
how we use the Internet so one of my
most I think what's most interesting to
me at the current moment is we are these
like ancient organisms from you know
over a hundred thousand years ago we
have very like strange things going on
that were useful a long time ago now we
have this crazy technology and our
brains interface enlightenment really
unfortunate ways like a great example is
just envy Envy was very useful in small
populations but it when you're connected
to the world suddenly at malfunctions so
I was trying to like get this idea of
social intuitionist theory about
truck-like tribalism and the internet
and this just the scope started growing
and growing and growing to the point
where to the point where I couldn't
handle it like I felt that I couldn't
make it into a video without missing a
huge it would have to become a
documentary right it would have to
become a documentary about the internet
it just couldn't be a video essay you
know what I mean that's that that was
one time I just was like cut it off
we're done yeah you need to move on this
talk about a movie yeah kind of the
follow-up question I had on that was but
to start that idea is from the righteous
mind right yes okay because I I like
skimmed it last night oh did you just a
little bit of yeah yeah but he started
talking about yeah social intuitionist
theory and how he thought that was
really I I mean it's fascinating to me I
and I it when I read that book it's sort
of connected with a bunch of other
things that I had been thinking for a
long time and it just I was like this
makes a lot of sense and I feel like he
is an author the author's name is
Jonathan Hite did his best to be
detached he didn't try and you know
bring a bunch of bias into his research
he says that like he was a lifelong he
for his life he felt a certain way and
by just doing this scientific research
he sort of moved his positions instead
of trying to move the research to his
positions who write which I felt like is
a great way to establish that this
person is writing something for you not
for them yeah I love that book I love
that book righteous mind
Jonathan height yeah isn't there a
subtitle like why politics and religion
divide good people why good people here
we go
disagree about politics and religion
yeah yeah yeah and that's brought up in
your video about persuasion persuasion
yeah and that's not even behalf of it in
my video that's a very basic like
overview of it because the book starts
with talking about the elephant and the
rider mm-hmm and the elephant and the
rider is about your emotional impulsive
reaction to things and the rider is your
rationality assessment of a situation
kind of thing and he just talks about
how the elephant the emotion is much
stronger ninety nine percent of a
hundred percent then we think we assume
more just do you somewhere you know
rational controlling everything but he
says you know that's not true
a lot of it is you actually coming in
with your all of your bias and all and
he describes it as moral taste buds of
things and your reaction to that will
immediately color how you see facts and
opinions and all information so the
reason in persuasion why it's so
important to establish common ground is
if you're just shouting at you know a
no-face on the internet there's no
connection with the 99% that Ella had
the elephant at all right and so
everybody's yelling at each other trying
to be rational but they never establish
any commonality between each other it's
just these strangers who think
there you know holier-than-thou or
smarter than the other person but it's
just basically words that are not
connecting with either side and usually
the assumption is if I can just put
together the perfect argument I can be
as rude or distasteful as I want and
they will just come over to my side
because of my you know your incredible
intelligence yeah yeah you know maybe
there's a small subset of the population
who is looking for that who is like oh I
only like really insightful I and see
ite insight you know people who insight
like you know anger and things like that
with truth but in terms of the general
population convincing people has got to
get on the same side first whether that
even be something like we share the same
taste in TV shows and this would imply
that either we need to change the way
that we talk about like things like
politics or like religion into his book
but or that we've just decided that we
don't care about convincing each other
and we're just kind of shouting well
within our tribe
exactly and that's also a big part of
the book too which is sort of like
because of social intuitionist theory
which argues that our ability to reason
has nothing to do with finding truth it
has to do with bringing people into our
group it's the same idea it's I'm only
saying this because I want to tighten my
own tribe right it has very little to do
with finding the truth between tribes so
that's the social intuition in this
theory and that's why when you read it
it's kind of um it's sad because you're
like wow it's really hard to argue
across these tribal divides yeah because
people are their intuitions are
different like so much so that they
don't know they're different I think one
of the most interesting parts that I got
to in that book was he starts talking
about these post hoc reasons for
like justifying your biases and
believing that those reasons are built
on some level of like absolute truth and
it makes sense of why on both sides of
the fence there are things that will
defend about our group that are kind of
Lee morally kind of morally
reprehensible like all these evangelical
conservatives who are like oh yeah Trump
saying you know grab her by whatever
that's totally [ __ ] like there's
reasons and they'll make all the excuses
or they'll be like well Bill Clinton did
it and vice versa and so it seems to me
like what seems to be like a
hypocritical stance actually is just
this playing out exactly how you'd
expect it to a hundred percent yeah yeah
it just plays out when you see all
controversy on the internet if you put
it through that framework you you
understand why there's so much hypocrisy
in politics and religion because the
writers there to justify behavior
regardless of whether it fits into like
a set of principles it's it's simply
there to justify what what has been done
mm-hmm and people are really good at it
Minh it's interesting to me something I
realize is actually the smarter you are
the better you are at fooling yourself
and like the more sophisticated your
arguments can get and the more you can
obfuscate abs abs obfuscate i'm
sophisticate the fact that you are
actually serving this you know purpose i
think there's yeah it there's thing like
people don't have ideas ideas have
people anyway that's what I think of or
ideologies or moral tastebuds of people
yeah I totally agree with that like this
I think the smarter people tend to be
able to justify pretty much anything
they want because they're able to create
these really highfalutin arguments like
whenever they need to write you know
it's a fascinating book I I highly
recommend it would you say that that's
actually because I was going to be one
of my questions like what's one
your favorite books that you recommend
all the time in terms of nonfiction I
highly recommend the righteous mind
I recommend anti fragile by Nassim Taleb
I think that is another really great
framework for people to think about and
then in terms of fiction i love a
confederacy of dunces it is my favorite
work of fiction my wife read that on our
honeymoon and she loved it
it is the funniest book I have ever read
in my life so you want to know something
interesting about this you may know this
but I'll just tell the story that guy he
couldn't get a publisher when he wrote
it and I think he shopped it around for
a while and the sad thing is he ended up
committing suicide I don't know if it's
because of that I think there probably
played a role later olio and afterwards
people it kind of got unearthed people
discovered it and his mom found it
his mom pendant his mom found it I think
under his bed and was like I think
reading through it and was like I think
this is really good so she brought it to
I can't remember it was a big publisher
or a local one yeah but she was pretty
much like you know this is a manuscript
it's not I don't it's not fully there
yet but it's pretty well hashed out and
I think we should I think it's really
publishable and great intuition she was
right and it's just another sad story of
a brilliant artist who you know after
they died their work becomes they get
recognized yeah a suddent yeah yeah I
need to read that book it's very funny
in fact there's a bar down that's what
she said she goes it's like it's
hilarious oh it's so funny there there
there's a there's a bar down the street
from here called night of joy and that's
the bar in how cool yeah that's really
neat yeah you're a champion we'll all
right great
I've been having a great time yeah
actually that's a fashion yeah I wasn't
expecting to have a great shocking
luckily we're having a great time so
credit to will I basically pitched this
idea to him and you immediately said yes
and then you like offered Europe your
place up to crash so I appreciate it man
of course I mean when a fellow creator
has an idea and they want to make it
happen I think the worst thing that
someone could do is say I'm not
interested you know like you want to
help the other person succeed obviously
without like tying down all of your
other stuff that you need to work on but
like if you reach out and and want
something to happen like I think you
have to help make it happen
to all of you who I'm gonna reach out to
after this you heard it here first
we'll scoters said by the way his name
is wills coder thank you get it right
please I'm pretty sure in my life 95% of
everybody says Schroeder which is
intuitive it that's why they do it it
that's what it looks like that's usually
what people are used to but it is coder
I said it right the first time
[Laughter]
all right let's see yeah do you have any
hobbies that no one knows about
oh that's interest that you've been
doing before video essays what you did
before video essays yeah I have a huge
hobby for a comedy I love comedy at one
point in my life I wanted to have that
be my job I wanted to write or perform
it and pretty much since high school
that was in my mind I was like oh I
would love to do this and I was obsessed
with stand-up and improv and you know
half-hour sitcom comedies things like
that who were your guys growing out
I went through a lot of phases yeah and
yeah and girls I I went through a lot of
phases I started with his name is no
longer as as pretty now but Bill Cosby
was the first comedian that I came in
contact with where I was like this is
awesome this is so cool my dad had tapes
of Bill Cosby yeah and here's his style
of delivery and like the fact that he
could sit in a chair and do all these
funny voices and and move his body in
interesting ways and the way he told
stories I think is what he's really
well-known for is just how perfect he
can play a bunch of different characters
within a small narrative right like
especially his family so Bill Cosby I
remember the dentist bit that that
always oh so funny
so funny he's got so many great bits
about like one of my favorites is he's
in the football locker room right and
and they're down at half and the coach
gets them riled up and people are
ripping stuff up you know in the locker
room they're going crazy and then they
all run out they're pumped up and the
door to the locker rooms locked so
everybody just immediately the energy
goes like because they're they're stuck
yeah so Bill Cosby was what started it
for me
and then I would say the SNL early on I
would listen to celebrity jeopardy and I
would download the the skits onto my
computer and and I would listen to them
I'd never watched them but I would
listen to them yeah I thought they were
very funny and then by highschool I got
more into like of course I was like an
apathetic teenager so who wasn't I got
into you know Bill Hicks
and George Carlin the types who would
sort of you know shake their fist at the
world right Sam Kinison those types and
I love those guys I still do but then I
also developed more taste for people
like Tina Fey and and Amy Poehler in the
more improv side of things where I
thought the highest level of comedy was
wit when people could shoot back and
forth without a script yeah that's
amazing and be funny for a whole
half-hour and you know the stand-ups are
pretty scripted the improvisers are just
pulling things out of thin air and so
both impressed me like to no end I think
comedy is so hard to be to be really
good at so at this point I think my my
taste buds for comedy have sort of gone
to almost everybody who is a successful
comedian right you know I don't have I'm
not too harsh now I think when I was
younger I was like no only the guys who
are really right are the the good ones
I've gotten into Norm Macdonald recently
he is like one of the best living Bobby
Ellis he's not only one of the best live
in comedians he's really he's the really
smart comedian to get back to your Bill
Cosby coming okay yes yes yeah yeah sure
I've heard this before
can you separate and this is kind of a
matter of an opinion art from the artist
can you separate it can you separate art
from the artist
I don't think so I think what's
interesting is and this is this is again
sort of the emotional rational thing
like rationally you should be able to
separate the art from the artist but
knowing that can you still go back and
watch house of cards and not think about
Kevin Spacey's thing like can you
separate yeah I probably not I don't
think so so even if you can rationally
I can separate the art from the artist I
don't think your brain is capable of
doing it once you know something at
least it's really hard yeah I know but I
think if we were to treat it purely
logically I think you can but yeah no no
way when you like are emotionally
affected vison right right what are some
small routines art your day that you
find to be really helpful or you think
people would benefit from doing them
like some people would be like
meditation maybe yeah you're gonna get
it with like a bunch of cliches let me
do a get like give them to me yeah so
the at least what I try to do first
thing in the morning is write three
notes of gratitude
so like things that I'm thankful for
that's first thing in the morning where
did you learn that I have no idea it I
think it came I'm sure it came from a
podcast or a video or something I have
no idea the origin but it came from the
Internet is my guess
and so I that's probably the most
ingrained routine I have then after that
I would say exercise is like if I don't
go for a run or I don't do something
similar like my day is not as good as it
could have been that's a big one mm-hmm
and again meditation is awesome I don't
I'm not like as disciplined as some
people are who are like going through a
program and you know getting
increasingly making it harder for
themselves as they go I just listened to
one recording every day mm-hmm it's a
guided meditation right and I really
like it
those routines are big and then there's
another one I guess actually before the
gratitude notes is make your bed big one
that comes from what's-his-name
I can't remember his name right now but
he is a an old Navy
commander and my friend had this had his
book on his shelf and I said can I
borrow that and then I read it's like
ten it's basically ten rules that you
should have that he learned from the
Navy SEALs all right first one being
make your bed because there's so much
uncertainty in life that you need to
have you need to start every day with a
small victory no matter even if it's
just making your bed there needs to be
some stability before the uncertainty of
life kicks in and I think just whether
you think it or not it's helping your
brain in some way get going with the day
and then there are other days where like
I take a shower and I'm like that was
the biggest wind today that's as far as
I'm gonna get another thing but I think
those routines are really big for me I'm
trying to think oh and then the last one
is like everybody should pick up a book
and try to read for at least an hour and
if you came two hours that's what I try
to go for every day it's not always
gonna happen but I have found that spend
putting aside an hour to two hours a day
for reading instead of an hour to two
hours of flashing screens in front of
your face is is far more beneficial to
your life than anything else it doesn't
have to be you know a productive book
that's teaching you about how to live
better or or some new theory it could be
detective fiction that gets you going
but as long as you're reading for an
hour at least a day I think is really
big do you think that there well there
is because I think maybe one day you
could argue there will be but do you
think there really is any replacement
for books because obviously you and I
are engaged in kind of like a condensing
information people are very into let's
get down what you need to tell me into
his little words as you possibly can I
don't want to waste my time it's like
the age a very short attention spans you
know all this kind of stuff and for good
reason
yeah yeah but you should everybody feels
like they're very short on time yeah
which is true I mean time is the most
valuable resource but not sure oh for
sure
money yeah okay
I don't accept that at all well well
actually people quite literally trade
their time for money every single day
they trade eight hours of the time for
sure
but there's a dollar amount at which you
will say this is worth my time yes that
is true but just as a thought experiment
time you have six months to live
do you care about money at all here's
why I don't love this premise why not
because this is at either extreme it's
kind of useless like if you have
basically if you have no material
possession or no ability to like get
anything even if you live a lot longer
it's kind of like whatever but at the
same time if you trade all if you're
like super rich and you have no time
that's bad there has to be some there's
obviously a divorce yeah of you you know
getting some external wealth to help you
with life having more time and an easier
life I'm not saying that I'm saying that
when it comes down to brass tacks
you could have zero money and you would
want that time those six months and you
could probably do okay just having that
time here I just wanted to play devil's
eye I love devil's advocate I love now
I'm coming off like the materialistic
guy like you just said happy medium so
like even you even you don't say like
the only thing that matters is my bank
account you know like that's ridiculous
well it is pretty high no I'm just
kidding
it's not obviously it's no no it's like
a beehive there sure actually by my own
decision making I don't think it is very
high because you were on video you
wouldn't be on YouTube if your bank
account was your
primary goal well especially on video
essays it's like oh well there it is
kind of a good time to be in video
essays there is an audience for it but
as far as monetizing it with the upload
release schedule like most video
essayist it's not the most lucrative of
no it's not the video essay model is the
curse the in a nutshell model I can't
pronounce there yeah don't even try it
the in a nutshell model which is like
you get enough of a loyal audience that
they want your content no matter how
long it takes you to make it and then
that in itself is sustainable and that
you're hopefully your content is so
desirable and informational that like I
think they've even been sponsored by the
Gates Foundation so yeah that's true so
like that is it's just a different goal
right right the Logan Paul of the world
the way he makes money is you know
constantly uploading videos right that's
a different it's just a different
business model yeah but the thing is is
he can bring in almost as many viewers
on one video that in a nutshell will
bring in on one video and they he
produces 30 times but what I have kind
of enjoyed watching is things like
patreon things where people can support
you outside of just ad revenue have
really changed what is possible to
create the quality you can put into a
video 100% because I was like I was
looking at YouTube
remember when like animations were
really big on YouTube and they would get
you know a bunch of YouTube killed anime
animation like I forget when but it was
not that long ago yeah they pretty much
the problem was you just weren't gonna
be making the kind of money needed to
put in the hours because it's just a
very time-intensive thing and yeah I
think the the equation has been changed
a little bit by things like patreon that
and but it's significant it helps the co
it's changes a lot and it's only going
to get better I think I talked in brief
exchange with jack conte who's the
founder of patreon and he is like super
super optimistic about the direction of
creators on the internet and and having
to add model sort of not not I don't
think it'll ever be phased out but it's
not going to hold as much weight for
creators in the future which i think is
is gonna be great how that's gonna
happen I don't know it was just a short
Twitter exchange but I think just
knowing that he has a vision that is
super positive and he's just working
hard on it every day
I think he's he sees really good things
happening in the future for people who
are on patreon and creators on the
Internet yeah in general I can very
easily I'm surprised it hasn't rolled
out yet so something like people who are
really good at monetizing their creators
is like twitch I think is that in some
ways gold standard of like if you have
seventeen thousand concurrent viewers on
Twitch
that's like more than probably five
hundred thousand subscribers as far as
your ability to sustain yourself so I
think one thing that I was I'm surprised
YouTube has it rolled out and I think
they will in the future is some kind of
sponsorship through YouTube have you
seen the buttons no they have the button
but I have you heard of twitch Prime
yeah
okay so twitch prime is tied to Amazon
and you get a free twitch Brent and that
has really increased the ability for
twitch to make write it make its
creators money I think YouTube will do
the same thing with YouTube's bread
where if you have a YouTube write
account you can do a monthly
subscription to a creator and it helps
them and cost you nothing kind of thing
I would be shocked if they don't do that
because they're read subscriptions would
go way up which I don't think they're
doing that well with red I am not
positive about why I don't think red has
been doing as well as they hoped right I
think that they had these creators that
were popular on the platform and they
want to develop shows with them like
kind of TV shows and what turned out
happening was like the people who sued
described to those you know
personalities were there for the
personalities they weren't there to
watch them go on a TV show and so the
audience didn't want to see the red
showed they wanted to see the
personality making the content of it
that they've always been making so
something I've thought about recently is
whether or not it's too far of a brand
extension for YouTube to try to become
like TV which they have clearly been
trying to do they tried with red and
they've even done a beauty YouTube TV
right I read this book about branding
where they talk about how a lot of
brands assume that their audience will
follow them wherever they go
so for example Coors did a it was Coors
or Miller and I'll say it right here
they did a bottled water and it was like
Coors spring water or whatever yeah and
it was like done in two years of like
trying to launch this thing because
people associate it with this thing and
the Association is actually almost what
kills them in the end because it's like
we just don't see you as that and I
think for most people who think of
YouTube they're thinking of the U and
YouTube and you don't think of like I
Love Lucy or like you know house of
cards or anything like that you think of
just a guy with a camera or two guys
with two cameras right or so the
perspective changes yeah yeah two guys
the two cameras in a hot room my dad the
the funny thing I think well okay so
similar example is like Nike I forget
who said this but he said Nike could get
into the potato chip business they have
a marketing team they have the money
they could make potato chips do you
think that would succeed long term for
Nike probably not they still they're
known to sell sneakers in there they're
an athletic wear company so even though
you're changing from one form of visual
medium to another form of the visual
medium I think that gap is large enough
that the perspective difference for an
audience member is too large yeah to be
like oh I don't see this person as
actor I see them as one of my friends
you know what I mean
one of the weird things is there's there
are few companies who've done it so like
the rare exception is like virgin so
they have virgin has like Virgin Mobile
they have like Virgin Airlines and they
have Virgin Records like they started as
a record company right or a label I'm
not sure which but anyway they've been
able to just basically but they've kind
of made that their brand is they kind of
go into all these different spaces and
they bring the Virgin model or the
virgin you know attitude and but that
seems to be kind of the exception rather
than the norm and for YouTube I think
they're not the exception
it seems that I'm trouble with it yeah
if you're a big tech company you can
branch out into a lot of different types
of tech I think but I think it's much
harder for a company that is known for a
very specific product to branch out into
anything else yeah but you know I could
be wrong
my knowledge of marketing and and how
businesses have grown in interesting
ways is not is below par for sure it
interests me but my my like knowledge of
the history of certain corporations and
how they succeeded no idea alright so
most people don't know most people don't
know and even I didn't know until and I
follow you pretty closely until I really
started to dive in yeah you didn't start
on you YouTube exactly you started with
this thing called ACS mm-hmm it's the Al
Capone II show they'll come funny show
and it's actually where his logo comes
from correct yeah so I'll give you some
background on the logo first so called
the Al Capone II show growing up one of
my nicknames was scooter pony people
called me scooter pony that's great yeah
and why that is another great question I
don't know okay there was a
a mentor of mine who threw it at me one
time
hey Skoda bunny you know can you help me
with this or you know and then just
stuck forever and it flowed really well
so he said it once that's gonna be a
meme from now let's go to pony yeah so
nice it was a name that you know I
didn't dislike it was is kind of funny
and fun and it flowed nicely right off
the tongue yeah
so it just stuck with me forever and
then I was like oh now I'm trying to
start a brand online or at least a logo
for a show why don't I just keep the
pony thing and have someone draw me a
logo that works for that and I reached
out to somebody who made that logo and I
thought first drive it was great and
here we are now in terms of the actual
show itself an Al Capone side of the Al
Capone II show yeah so that's the
mystery to me and it should remain a
mystery because I'm not sure I even
though I called it death is amazing I so
I I was I think one thing that a lot of
people have trouble doing when they're
creating a channel or a show is like
what are we gonna call it
you know what should the name of this be
yeah and and that's really hard and it
it's even more painful to spend you know
weeks thinking about it and then come up
and settle on a weird name you know and
I thought it was such a silly like
looking back it's a totally silly name
to have chosen but I'm sure there was a
reason you know when I started that six
years ago this is a podcast by the way
Al Capone he shows a product yes to
clarify to clarify its and I started it
the comedy podcast is a sketch comedy
podcast yeah and I started it right out
of college first time people this is
their first time because I'm a huge
believer in just for creating necessity
for you to make things so I was really
interested in
and getting into comedy and so I said I
need to start something that's gonna
force me to create content and get
better at this right and so I said okay
sketch comedy podcast it's gonna force
me to write it's gonna force me to like
do voices and that's exactly what it was
and you know I was just looking back now
I'm sure a lot of it's very
cringe-worthy I feel like I worked
pretty hard on some of them and I'm sure
some of them stand the test of time but
really it's just a great example of
somebody making something before they
became known by a wider group of people
and that project never really being that
significant but being a part of them as
a creation yeah what do you think you
that taught you about the creative
process because video i season sketch
comedy there doesn't seem to be too well
that was more my interest in comedy and
I was I was trying to practice writing
humor the reason is well I don't want to
get into the reason I switched quite yet
but the reason I created that again is
because I'm a firm believer in like just
practice until you're perfect for shiny
thing for sure
and specifically releasing content I
think is important and not obsessing
over this is my new show yeah you know
oh this needs to this little piece of
audio has like a little blip in it you
know and I can't release this until this
is silenced something I I'm sure you've
gotten this to is like hey I'm starting
a video essay channel tell me what you
think how should I start and what I
always say and this is really what I
believe is not only just start but
really try to try to finish something as
quickly as possible that you like you
like and it's the best you probably
could have done and maybe three to five
days or something like that
and just iterate upon it because no
matter how much time you spend on it
you're gonna look back and even a month
and you're gonna just cringe at it
yeah and that's okay because that's just
that's part of it means that what you
say as well I I would I whenever I get
an email asking for advice about
starting a channel especially video
essays channel is simply you just have
to start doing it because as soon as you
you know go through the process that's
how you learn in the process I think
I've told you this story which is that
the teacher and the ceramic pot teletig
I loved I loved it yes so right so it's
the beginning of the semester and the
teacher divides the classroom to on the
left side
she says this half of the class you're
going to be graded based on the weight
of your pots so at the end of the
semester you know those with forty
pounds get an A 30 pounds B etc this
other half of the class is going to be
judged on one perfect pot and you know
that is all you get you get one pot so
the semester goes on half the class is
making as many as they can the other is
theorizing theorizing how am I gonna
make this one pot perfect at the end of
the semester the guys who made all the
quantity had the best pots because these
people started and only made one they
didn't have enough trial and error to
make a perfect pot so the guys who made
the weight also made the quality ones
right so I think that's just a great
analogy of you just have to keep doing
it and as you trial and error you start
to realize who this part of the process
is not streamlined it's not good oh this
is how you make this more visually
appealing oh this is a better way to
edit my audio you just have to keep you
know trial and error things and
eventually you're gonna get there that's
literally all it is and it's all it is
but it's not intuitive when you haven't
done it before right and that's what I
think people get hung up on is they do
think that like I can perfectly craft if
I just think hard enough
if I just do it enough and yeah so
that's I think it's a really important
lesson I think the best advice that I
can give someone who's starting a video
essay channel is watch your favorite
video essayists and then ask yourself
how did they do that so I really like
those three seconds how do I make that
in you know my editing program because
once you start asking those questions
then you're gonna have to teach yourself
how to make it and then you're going to
be able to make the exact same product
so you say oh you know they have a
moving background
I got a I'm gonna research how they have
a moving paper background right oh they
have you know something wiggling in the
air like this how do I do that you know
how do I make it so the edges are
vignette 'add like all those kinds of
things you just have to ask yourself
while you're watching ya and then as you
write them down how do they do that that
that you're gonna figure it out and I
think it's it's important to note
because I think some video essay is have
backgrounds in film but I at least know
because we talked a little bit I think
you majored in what again history
history I majored in chemical
engineering neither of us have any
background in video editing or anything
like that so I made short films with my
friends in high school and and but
that's very different from video essays
absolutely it's very different from like
proper schooling on the cow do you make
and write the school of hard knocks
really is how you learn video editing
and there's no more helpful tool than
just YouTube tutorials just keep
watching them and then do them with the
person and you're gonna figure out how
to do a lot of stuff I think there are
some really like good animation classes
if you're willing to shell out like five
hundred dollars and take like a
three-week class and become pretty darn
good
but that's for like after effects
animation - like it's a little bit
different when you're just learning how
to keyframe things around you know you
can I can get you started yeah actually
I will get you started for sure yeah
yeah so I wanted to ask you who are some
creators that either you follow in the
video essay space that don't get
attention that you think are doing
really good work or who are some like
guilty pleasures of YouTube that you're
like you can't stop watching you can
choose either one yeah okay well I'll
answer both so I think what's so great
about that as a video essay channel her
name is Grace she is so good at editing
and she writes these beautiful pieces
about all different kinds of things but
I noticed that one of her big focus
focuses was on how space is used in in
film and and things like that and I
think it's a really interesting angle
and she's great so highly underrated
check her out
gosh that's that's hard because there
are so many great video essayists that
like I feel like need attention but you
know Thomas flight is great beyond the
frame he actually works for like actual
video essayist companies now and like
doesn't make stuff for his channel
anyone but he's really great and another
sort of person who's right around our
size as great as entertaining the elk is
great I've heard of him yeah yeah so
those are those are some of the video
essayist I really like I get to see I
wouldn't I wouldn't say that I consume
video essays like
a rabid YouTube consumer in fact I don't
think I consumed that much content as I
used to
all right but I would say my juicy
followings like okay my friends and I we
all have some of us have moved to
different parts of the United States
after graduating from college and one of
the things that we do now one of the
ways that we get to reconnect is we play
video games together over the internet
and we hang out okay like what so
recently we've been playing the game
everybody's been playing we were playing
for a night together and it's just so
like you can say whatever you want about
that I play for tonight it's great but
like when you're with three of your
friends you know running around and
having a good time it is
it is one of the best ways for my friend
in Chicago and my friend in Boston to
come on the night where instead of like
a Skype call we can just all hang out
right and and do an activity together
and so what has sort of expanded from
that experience is like we're we also
like to talk about the people who are
really good so we'll be like oh you know
this guy it's really one of the guys we
really like is a guy named Daquan and
and he's just a really good player yeah
and he's really funny and so we will
like talk about him and other players
who have YouTube channels right and so
it it's it's a guilty pleasure because
it's sort of like it's also become a way
to bond with my friends about like
something that we all do yeah
and so I would say like funnily enough I
consume a good amount of Fortnight
content because it's just something me
and my friends do together I got in that
like I probably played that game for
like four weeks until I realized
because I have a bad luck I have a
really bad habit of like right after I
came back from my honeymoon
I like was looking for a game and I got
into have you ever heard of terraria no
it's like it's it's it's just a stupid
game but my personality is such that if
it has any kind of like skill dimension
or latter dimension or like you know
it's an RPG or anything like that
immediately that's all I want to do this
is I get better or level up whatever it
is and so I probably spent the next five
days like my wife would never see me
like I would be up all night till like
basically 4:00 in the morning the first
time I played the game I put in 9 hours
straight on it yeah fortnight and
fortnight is like the hyper produced
version of that like I mean it's it's
even more fun it's even more addicting
it's incredibly addicting to the point
where like I was just reading this thing
about slot machines how like there's my
machines are engineered to create near
wins and like that's the exact feeling
you have playing that game which is like
I feel like I almost won that one and
then you're like I'm gonna I'm gonna
ready all right I'm gonna do this again
but what I was shocked by is when you
start you actually don't feel that bad
because even though even if you die like
pretty quick you're still gonna be like
50th you're like you're like oh I'm
better than you know average or whatever
right I think it's more fun to just play
yeah you know like I don't really care
about necessarily the place unless it's
like I'm in the top like unless I'm
close yeah like it if I get bottom
whatever I just want to get out and and
start playing [ __ ] like I don't feel bad
about the yeah yeah but it's it started
as something that I enjoy playing on my
own and then it was clear that all my
friends also were doing that yeah and
then now it's kind of been the reverse
is like I wouldn't play it unless all of
us were playing it together and having a
good time and like I don't turn it I
wouldn't turn it on unless we've all
texted each other that we're gonna play
tonight
yeah so one thing that I
I like I I didn't do for a while and
then I got like this is really how I
stopped playing video games you guys
I'll start watching content and I'll
think I'll never get to this level so
let me drop being in a joy yeah let me
just enjoy how good like ninja is and
just enjoy like these insane noscopes
and this is just my way of vicariously
like still kind of holding a connection
to the game but not feeling like I have
to go you know play it myself and do it
but no like actually visually that's one
of the most stunning games because the
things you can do with like Matt's all
that kind of stuff is really oh the game
itself is like yeah I don't know they
probably brought in someone who's like a
social engineer who like know is like
alright you need to put colors behind
the guns cuz like the more colors in
something makes it more addicting you
need to engineer the sound that you know
every time you jump from the bus that is
like a an addicting sound like they have
it all perfected to the point where it's
just like really addicting and I
understand why people like to watch it
instead of watching a TV show like why
people queue up to watch all those
gamers yeah cuz you know aside from the
games addictiveness it's entertaining to
watch yeah like even even a streamer
who's completely silent and doesn't say
a word the gameplay it is is fascinating
and interesting yeah I thought it is
really interesting and I think it's did
you ever play like any of the MOBAs or
anything like that
no so that was the thing like this is
battle royale this is like the new thing
that's huge there's nothing before that
that were like called MOBAs and I think
the advantage of battle Royales are that
there's so much more accessible for
laymen like with MOBAs you had to know
all this stuff about the characters what
the characters move dota and dota okay
Lowell you know all that kind of stuff
but what's interesting is like battle
Royales are very easy to understand I
mean as far as just a guy shooting
another guy whoever can shoot better
basically there's strategy that goes
deeper than that but you can appreciate
it on a surface level whereas if you
watch a dota game unless you've played
dota before you're completely lost as to
what's happening you know what's
interesting about that and this is
somewhat of a straight thing but a lot
of my friends didn't appreciate soccer
until they played FIFA because when you
play FIFA you start to realize oh this
is why this formation does this this is
why you pass in this situation instead
of taking the shot and then because you
know those ins and outs the games and
there's a whole new window yeah into the
game and I think it's the same thing as
like sometimes you just need to
understand something until you can
appreciate it I guess that's a hilarious
analogy for video essays - yeah you're
right can you appreciate a movie until
you see like the directors crazy theme
that they wanted to put in here I don't
know like would you appreciate this and
Caine more if someone explained all
citizen came to you or should you just
appreciate it by watching says ok yeah
so philosophy seems like it's a
through-line through part of your work
like yes
bringing up philosophers you like here
or there or discussing the larger themes
of works as being philosophically based
who are your favorite philosophers do
you have any that you really connect
like connect connect with exactly yes I
think my favorite philosophers David
Hume because he sort of parted with a
lot of philosophers who were just like
we need to create super logical proofs
and and and think about this only
rationally and Hume was like no I think
everything's emotion based and I agree
with that and a lot of like I think
Schopenhauer has a quote that where he
says there's more to be learned in a
page of Hume than most philosophical
works of the last couple centuries
you know what actually I kind of want to
check that because I don't know if it's
quite that hyperbolic sure check it's
like I think he says like it might not
be like the past couple centuries but
like the you know yeah the great
philosophical works or whatever right
and so I I totally feel that like there
were numerous times when I read an
inquiry concerning the principles of
morals where I was like yes like this is
how I feel you know and so much of
philosophy is breaking bounds but also
reinforcing belief so like a lot of
philosophy that you read will open your
mind to huge new practical ideas other
parts of it are important because it's
like yes that so much reinforces how I
feel right
Humes the big one well I should do this
first
Schopenhauer on him What did he say
where is you made a video about children
yeah I did a video about his uh about
how dirty dirty or a dirty tricks janux
yeah absolutely and actually that kind
of goes along with your idea that
Schopenhauer looked a Hume who was kind
of breaking from some of the traditions
because that book was very breaking
against before that philosophers had
been very concerned with like how to
make these perfectly logical arguments
and Schopenhauer comes along and says
well the common man does not make
perfectly logical arguments they make
arguments from you know fallacious
arguments all the time yet to win so
it's like well let me try to codify you
know all these how do they do it the
common man yeah how they do it the exact
for sure I'm totally gonna get this I
just found it there is more to be
learned from every page of David Hume
than from the collective philosophical
works of Hegel Herbert and
flyer mucker taken together so I totally
hyperbolized that but I think that's
pretty like that's a that's a firm
statement to say especially Hagel like
there's more to be learned from every
page of him than the entire
philosophical works of like some of ya
you know especially from Hegel
although Hegel famously writes terribly
yes ok back to a favorite philosophers
Hume number one all-time and then after
Hume I'd say Seneca stoicism yeah he was
the best writer about it yeah
at least his letters tend to make me
feel like I'm learning more about it
then some of the other works like
epictetus is great because he's kind of
funny and I think humor is a is a great
way to spice up teaching yeah Marcus
Aurelius his meditations also one of my
favorite it's on my desk every day I
love that book
so the Stoics in general I guess is an
easy way to say it I think the Stoics
have the most practical philosophy that
you know someone in the modern world if
they need to follow something because a
lot of philosophies highfalutin and it's
like you know does God exist type
questions that are fun to theorize about
but we're like what philosophy can I go
to to feel practical you know and that's
a big divide I think stoicism I think is
incredibly practical but besides that I
love John Stuart Mill because of his
just as small little treatise on Liberty
like he's so right about so many things
in that and then I'd probably say
Spinoza
just because his way of thinking about
the world is just crazy and awesome and
like his conception of God can really
change the way how you see the entire
world other than that I love all
different philosophers but those are
like I guess the Mount Rushmore right
group to change the game for you change
the game change the game but yeah if you
haven't read some Hume read some
stoicism and but you don't read Spinoza
and read on Liberty those are my like
tops my tops nice cool
oh and I'll push two books is it on push
it so there are three books see he
really is here this is actually my
bookshelf wait where's the I've been
passing it for mine this entire time I
don't know where it okay so I don't know
where it is but there's one book written
by and this is this is outside of
individual works so there's one book
written by the famous Bertrand Russell
history of Western philosophy it is by
far the best history and summary of
philosophy up to I don't know the date
but I like before weakens vacant sign I
think but these are just as good if not
better
the dream of reason starts with the
Greeks and then the dream of
enlightenment continues after that with
the American by the same person right
same dude journalist for The Wall Street
Journal I think but these are so like I
haven't found any books besides Bertrand
Russell's history of Western philosophy
that are as good as these two I think
what scares so many people away from
philosophy is that like it's when you
read certain books you're like I can't
follow this at all you know a lot of
times too they're in direct response to
a kind of an age of thinking
right so it's like you have to start
tracing back and it's a lot it's a lot
yeah those are great those are great I
highly recommend if you don't read
philosophy to at least give it a try
because you never know I could change
your opinion on how to live your life
yeah life will live a life well-lived
who knows what that truly means so we
live in a more connected age than ever
but also a more distracting age than
ever and you address this idea in the
attention economy where you argue that
it's not an Information Age actually the
real currency is attention I think for
someone like me who wants to be highly
productive I think for a lot of people
the question is how do you harness
technology without suffering the
drawbacks of so many media sites being
so good at drawing you in drawing you in
fortnight sure anything the you have any
solutions are not all that clear I think
they depend on from person to person
because so much of it is habitual like I
don't use Facebook anymore but without a
doubt you know every couple days I'll
type FA into my search bar and it will
autofill Facebook and I'll hit enter I
didn't choose to do that my habitual
brain FA Facebook how do we get out of
those habits is the harder question like
rekt I I think it's really a balance
like can a service that requires your
attention to survive also be beneficial
to you and do things that don't grab
your attention so like can snapchat make
the decision to kill streaks because
they ruin teenagers lives you know what
I mean like streaks is made to grab them
all annual attention right and have them
keep sending things to their friends
what a disaster in terms of you know
having a kid put their phone down right
so it's really up to the the services
it's not that up to you I believe that
very firmly I think they have grasped
how easy it is to exploit human
psychology now that you aren't really in
control the only things that you can
really no I'm dead serious the only
things that you can really do are to
turn it off that's what I've done has
turned things off so for example I don't
have that I don't have browser on my
phone anymore so that I can't search
anything and like it's restrict you can
delete your browser you can restrict it
yeah and you can always enter the
passcode to unrestricted sure but I
think by deleting the habitual sideswipe
press and when you swipe and it's not
there your brain is like oh I won't do
it you know what I mean yeah same thing
goes for or you're interrupting actually
interrupting the pattern in the power of
habit doing the routine yeah there's the
what actually you're interrupting a the
cue near the trigger the trigger here
you're interrupting the cute
so yeah in the power of habit which is a
great book yeah got what's what's his
Charles doing Charles doing yeah he
talked about there's the trigger the
routine and then the rewards and you
basically have to cut off I believe you
have to change the routine right yeah so
so but but before you can change the
routine you have to figure out what the
cue and the reward are yeah because if
like I think the example he's is from
himself as
at work every day I would get up and go
get a cookie and then I when I got up I
got to socialize with my coworkers and
then I get to sit down he wanted to get
rid of getting the cookie part he
realized that the only reason he
actually got up was because he wanted to
talk to his co-workers and take a social
break so instead he replaced the routine
with I just got triggered to go get a
cookie instead of getting that cookie
I'm going to go socialize with my
co-workers someone who's free whatever
yep and then I get the same reward so
the I guess his idea of changing a habit
is keep the cue and the reward the same
but consciously change the routine yeah
yeah I've done it I've done something
like that with soda it's like cut it
into club soda right yeah yeah it's like
you still get that the fizziness you get
all that kind of stuff
and people look at it like yeah that's
not that good and compared to water
that's true but as a replacement for our
sorry compared to soda that's true but
it's like a replacement for is a
replacement for it pretty good yeah but
yeah no yeah so there's a great what
Seltzer is very different from club soda
and scoter wants you to know that yeah
Seltzer's way better than club soda Oh
with this guy's talked about so but the
original question was like how how how
does someone change the habit how does
someone who wants to work right not get
distracted at otally uh I think a big
thing is is you need to change your
environment so I think a lot of people
see it as a willpower thing which is the
wrong way to frame in mmm-hmm so a lot
of a lot of you know gurus will say like
you just need the willpower to change
your thing which is like I guess there's
some there's some willpower to stuff I
get it but I think there's nothing more
powerful
environment so if you can change an
aspect of your environment like let's
say I noticed when I'm writing a script
that you know every time I take a break
I go down a hole of twitter and then all
the sudden I'm out of it 45 minutes
later then maybe instead I should go
right in a coffee shop and see if the
environment helps at all
I think environmental triggers are huge
because when you change the environment
you change the cue like the cue isn't
the same if you're in a do in a
different environment yep
that's a big thing well that's the
answers that I wanted to get at because
the having like putting it all on the
app or the service is you're probably
right that as far as like for most
people nothing's gonna change until the
app changes I agree with that
however that leaves like me or somebody
at home who's like really desperate to
like oh I need to focus more or you know
whatever just kind of like I'm there who
are really trapped yeah
because you know the but you can make
meaningful change by yourself but you
won't have like a complete unless you're
gonna become like a Luddite and have a
spray phone and my well so this isn't my
idea but there's the idea of batching
but you have to get in the habit of
batching which is to say like in the
morning after you complete your routine
or whatever you batch or emails then
that's the only time you get to check
your email or you could do it twice a
day here a lot of the problems people
have is like the consistent I'm every
time I get a text I get a few if what it
is or every time I get an email I got to
make sure I see what it is instead what
you should do is split it into two times
per day where you're like this is the
only time I'm gonna have to do it all
the other times I'm not allowed to do
this and that is a huge help because
most emails and most texts totally do
not need to be answered right away right
like if
what you can tell your family is like
the only way I'm gonna pick you need to
call me if there's like an emergency
because I feel like a lot of people are
worried that if I keep it over there for
eight hours while I do work something I
could miss out on like something really
bad right just make sure that you're the
people who regularly contact you know
that you are from whatever 10:00 to 5:00
p.m. or doing intense work and sorry
your phone's gonna be off or your
phone's not gonna be close to you
there's no problem with saying that you
know there's no problem with doing that
and then again with the emails like do
it at 10:00 do it at 6:00 that's it like
there's no reason why an email between
6:00 and 10:00 the next day needs to be
answered unless like you you're running
walk and I think and I think a lot of
people too they have like habits of like
checking Twitter all the time or
checking to see if they got that
meditation the Twitter I'm I'm bad about
Twitter
I'm also bad about YouTube because
there's onion yeah I'm on YouTube so
that was big of YouTube from Twitter is
a big problem novelty new ideas always
yeah yeah I guess I could explain what I
do I don't know if it would be helpful
for people sure no come on give us what
you do like well okay if you're a
computer guy or girl got to get rid of
that habit
if your computer person if you're a
computer person if you're a computer
person you want to use RescueTime it's I
can't remember how much it costs you're
gonna have to spend money on it but it
keeps track of all your usage is it an
apposite of software it's software it's
it's on your computer okay and it keeps
track of everything keep track of your
use of video games your use of Adobe
programs your use of the internet and
what sites you go to
and so and then it has a AI or maybe
it's just you know chosen by humans and
you can edit this to is it has a
productive scale from negative 2 to 2 to
being very productive negative to being
very distracting and I don't think
there's anything more effective than at
the end of the week getting an email
from rescuetime saying you spent 21
hours on entertainment this week and you
spent 30 hours on work on design and
composition over there and you're at the
end of the week you say oh my gosh like
I didn't without knowing it I played
video games went on Twitter and watched
a movie enough time to be just short of
how much dye worked you know what I mean
like no man you and when you see that in
front of you I think that's a great way
to just be like okay yeah because for a
lot of people it's like they don't know
that they're doing well your video
they're bleeding time yeah yeah I did a
I did a thing for a while it became like
it was a lot of upkeep but I had this a
really rigorous time management system
where like I tracked at last
every little lasted for like several
months my acid actually lasted a while
because especially when I first started
like doing YouTube I was like I was
determined not to get sidetracked until
I basically from the time I woke up to
the time that I went to bed and I know
these like buckets for like what
classified as you know work what
classified as whatever and that was
totally eye-opening to do the same thing
and I would have like weekly progress
reports and like you know but it became
too too complicated I like I likes a
software that is doesn't for it does it
for you exactly yeah all right the one
thing is is how does it know if like
let's say I have Adobe open but I'm not
using it it's only active lenses it's
act it's only active it knows and knows
that you're being act
I want it yeah so like you could have
Spotify open and Adobe open but it's
only gonna keep track of Adobe if you're
perfect if Spotify was playing in the
back right and if I go and I click on
Lego I'm gonna go check Twitter or
whatever and I still have Adobe on the
other screen it's gonna count yeah so
what it does in that regard is like it
will measure out the productive versus
distracting so it could register like a
neutral half-hour where like you were
doing Adobe but you're also going on
Twitter and you're also check like
changing your Spotify songs it would
determine based on I don't know
complicated stuff that for this half
hour you actually weren't being that
productive it does like keep track of
like this half hour you were only using
Adobe now do they have that for the
phone I don't know I haven't used it for
the phone my because because my problem
isn't the phone my problem is the work
space right I'm sure other people have
bigger problems with the phone you know
I have a bigger problem with the
workspace personally yeah but I know
life ends on the person like I know
other people who have much bigger
problems with phone than their computer
my problem is the computer if if anybody
has a problem with the phone there's a
great app called freedom which is like
it's just an internet blocker so you can
go like oh I want to be blocked for 30
minutes or an hour or whatever it'll
sync up to your computer too and you can
do like all sorts of like social block
sites but I like I like this rescue time
I haven't heard of it before rescue time
is great and they have great support
because there's an element of reflection
involved which I really like right yeah
you manage massive and you don't need
you don't need to be like even if you
know you're getting distracted like
you're not gonna cause like for example
let's say you run freedom and you just
want to be distracted that week what
you're just not gonna run freedom that
week right I mean whereas rescue time
it's like just passive so it'll report
on your bad behavior as well right and
just be like okay you should probably
should get it together as far as like
right you need to look at you need to
assess yourself and make a change but
like it is eye-opening to be like oh I
didn't realize I spent 50 hours playing
fortnight this week do you think that
helped you do you think it hello big
time nice oh yeah so that's like a big
thing for you yeah
rescue times huge and then there's
another one which I bet is not for
everybody but it's called beeminder
which is la it's it just is loss
aversion psychology so it's like if you
don't hit a certain you know goal
beeminder charges you so it's money loss
aversion I mean I think for the most
part in terms of getting getting goals
completed the two biggest things that
psychologists say are social pressure
and and and loss over like money like
losing money I've so the idea of like
the idea of like having to pay beeminder
$5,000 if you don't complete your novel
in two years gets people to write their
novels you know what I mean like it's
terrified yeah yeah so how do they know
to like so to give us a choice
you could you could set something as
simple as I want beeminder to link up
with my to-do list and you can set novel
do December 21st and then you can email
beeminder and be like this is the hard
date I am NOT allowed to check this box
on my to-do list app until that date
like you need to prove like b-minor is
that good like their support will be
like no you're a little weasel and
you're just gonna hit the box yeah yeah
yeah that's what I was wondering
and and complete it and so our systems
gonna update right but you can also tell
them I'm not allowed to do that and and
and they will make sure that you state
that's almost like a notary or something
like that well it's just it's pressure
it's it's actual pressure I like that
and that's one of that's one of the
things that people have such trouble
with is like they try all these
different things and then they are not
culpable is that the right word yeah
responsible yeah they're not they're not
responsible and then they just if it all
got a wave responsibility yeah if it
doesn't go well and so is like in terms
of getting stuff done if you're
self-employed that's a big one
so beeminder is great like I I think
loss aversion is a huge way to get stuff
done and that's a good program to use it
and it links up with all different stuff
like to-do lists if you want to get if
you can link it with RunKeeper so yeah
like if you want to write how many miles
you want to run ten miles a week yeah
and you can connect it with B minor and
said if I don't run ten miles this week
B minor is gonna charge me whatever
whatever you're not willing to lose
that's a good app like in conjunction
with other paying atten apps yeah and I
guess it's just it's really sad that we
have to do this like don't you think
that we have to like have additional
apps to help us do these things no in in
some ways I think that's super important
that those apps get developed because no
it's important that they exist I'm what
I'm saying is like it's sucks that we
have to use them like because otherwise
we'd like to sit here and not do the
things and like even if even if you
really want it to do something like
write a movies right so there's a good
chance you're not gonna do it there's
still a good chance even though you're
passionate about that that you're not
going to do right well we're just unable
to think about long-term goals all the
time and keep their weight in mind and
so it's like I I think you may have
mentioned this earlier about we have
hardware that doesn't fit what we're
using the tools that we're using and
it's like the tools that we are using
are so distracting and so good at always
having something novel like kind of in
maybe more interesting than writing your
screenplay or you know all these things
and so it's like you need software
that's on your side as well like on your
long-term goal side right yeah again
it's the interfacing ancient interface
with brand new thing that takes
advantage of ancient interface well yeah
I'm really looking forward to like I
feel like I feel like the Internet is
basically like a fire hose a fire
hydrant of information basically sure
you're not going to retain it all
and you have the input of maybe just
like a normal drink of water and so part
of that is like let's lower the output
and I'm like I need software to do that
for me
I want software to filter out so I video
less is unpopular yeah yeah yeah filter
out all the noise to get to a nice
little nectar of what I want yeah yeah
yeah yeah and that's also why it's
important to just turn it off and read a
book as well
but I totally agree with that analogy
it's like he can only drink so much
water coming from a fact well yeah I
I've actually got a better one because I
realized you need a good example for
resistors like with electricity
something is only useful if you can get
it to the voltage that your thing needs
like most right most don't need 120 volt
so a big part of all you know boards are
resistors to like step it down to
whatever exactly how much you need and
so it's the resistors part that yeah if
the resistor well I think that's an
important point because so many people
don't spend the time to create that
infrastructure to in order to create
those points of resistance and so they
just keep doing the same thing and it's
worth spending a week a month
narrowing closing the gap until you're
at that point at which point you can
more or less take your hands off of it
and accept what you've got right but if
you never create that infrastructure
you're gonna continue to just feel them
like bombarded with infinite information
and yeah and probably retain none of it
yeah so one question I've wanted ask is
what inspired you to get into video
essays like what was the turning point
that was it a person was it a video
it was the nerd writer I was god it was
a long time ago like I I hate to be one
of those people who's
I was one of the first you know
subscribers of that guy
but her 70,000 yeah I told ya right I
was one of the first 70,000 so like
that's a very new there you know you
could fit his fan base into football
stadiums at that point but like we we I
watched a video of his I can't remember
what video was I guess it was more of
like an a conglomeration of watching a
bunch at once probably but it I knew it
was his channel and I had done some
soul-searching this is sort of passing a
bunch of stuff but at the time I was
doing comedy I wasn't enjoying it I have
a really good group of friends and
working like the day job into comedy at
night was like you know I wasn't willing
to endure the long path to comedic
success to drop that it takes to drop
like my health my family my friends oh
you know all those things that most
people tend to have to drop in order to
spend the time to master something I
knew that I was not a prodigy it was
gonna take me probably a decade or more
and I just wasn't willing to do that and
so I was looking for I did some
soul-searching about comedy like why was
I even doing it and I think one of the
things that I was really why I fell in
love with comedy in the first place is
because it's like a place of ideas and
teaching and in that respect it's not
that different from writing of like an
educational piece because my
introduction to comedy was like the
Hicks the Carlin's the guys who were
like they're making is underneath the
kind of the ironic like mode of like
teaching through deconstructing
something was really fascinating to me
and I but interestingly enough and
that's a thing is I was more interested
in that aspect of it than
getting the laughs and so like I'm I
know for a fact I was also interested in
getting the laughs but it wasn't like
such a disease that I had that like if I
couldn't get laughs anymore I was I
couldn't live anymore
it was more like I'm willing to give up
not doing that to do something that I
know that I'm gonna like and we talked
about this yesterday I think which is if
you combine two skills and make them
into one thing yeah this is Scott Adams
quote yeah yeah that if you take two
things that you are you think you're
good at and you combine them that
immediately puts you way ahead of a lot
of other people who just have one skill
exactly and so like in my mind I was
like okay I'm not that bad at video
editing because I'd cut some films and I
bet I could teach myself really quickly
and I know that I've been taught by some
really good teachers to become a good
writer over a long period of time I have
those two skills
why don't I you know throw an axe at the
dartboard and then see if it sticks
and that's exactly what I do I out like
my first essay and I was just like I'm
gonna throw it into the void and it got
caught by a bunch of people yeah your
first essay did really well like I was
looking back at it I think it's almost
at a million right yeah I don't know but
it's it's probably I think long time but
it got caught immediately immediately
like it was you you got caught on read
read it was where it skyrocketed so like
I was talking to the wisecrack guys this
was a long time ago
yeah like probably at this point two
years ago but we were talking about like
how wisecrack got started and they said
the same thing they're like
reddit like yeah one of our videos
caught fire on reddit and I think that's
it's amazing what read it does for
creators and at the same time you can
post something to Reddit and it's
totally a dud so what's really
interesting that I find really cool
about reddit is unlike YouTube where
it's like it really matters if you have
this gigantic following on reddit you're
kind of it's like you're almost Eagle is
I used in my last piece of content could
have had you know it could have went to
are all you know been the biggest post
of all time your next post will be
judged just like everybody else's yeah
it's like has to be good on its own
merit right and that's a reason that new
creators like it's such a good place
it's great place for new creators that
said there are rabid fan bases who do
get creators videos to the top like
pretty regularly so like I think I've
noticed at least that h3h3 anytime they
post something their fans will they have
a very loyal fan base will get them with
it the first things yeah
videos on reddit which is great that's
it's great to have a fan base like that
but in terms of like as you were saying
the invent it's way more of a democracy
that's what was my point it's like I'm
YouTube it's so tough yeah for sure
well I at YouTube you're I think you're
much more at the the chokehold of the
algorithm like if it puts you in
suggested videos if it shows you to X
amount of people whereas read it's like
it's gonna show it and it you're more
likely to get random traction from 15
people who happen to be looking at new
videos I voted you
so yeah reddit was where the first video
essay stuck and and took off and then I
was like okay I'm you know now I have to
make the next one but that's the answer
though is like oh this is this is a type
of video I've never seen before right I
would love to do this so I think I
actually have one of the few
versions of this that do not come from
nerdwriter because I think a lot of SAS
are inspired look I liked him but I
started because I was really inspired by
like a combination of like say Frank
that is he's not like the president of
BuzzFeed which is really interesting
because he was like valued for like
really introspective content and then
now he's like the president of like the
biggest mass you know whatever content
in the world clickbait but i was
inspired by him and then i was inspired
by like the daily show you know these
these like really engaging so i started
and it's unlisted now but i had like
these like camera videos or like a turn
of the camera talks aren't true
yeah and then i was really interested in
the ability to use images like over here
because I noticed news occurs don't do
that was like oh this is an evolution so
then I started to do that in my videos
and I started to do more of them and
more of them and then all of a sudden I
was like why am I here at all like
what's the purpose of me being in frame
what's actually kind of communicate
taking this this communication to the
next level is the images cells like let
me just go all image yeah I think that's
and then I discovered the genre and then
I was like oh this totally makes sense
yeah I think that's a great way to go
about it the the the decision that I
think youtubers have to make in the
genre is am I going to combine education
with my personality or am I going to be
mostly education so like in a nutshell
nobody knows it's education anybody of
any of them are right like but John
Green is a company he's a personality
he's a personality but he's an
educational personality yeah so it's you
have to make the choice of whether what
you're gonna do
what's your choice I don't think I've
made it yet I think for now it's just me
narrating but I used to be like yeah
necessarily I don't know I've been
flipping on that I but that is
definitely a choice I have to make
everybody's gonna make it because
because you
tube is inherently a personality based
platform yep so you have to decide if
you're gonna use that or not right like
if you tried to make an original show it
suddenly flips this we talked about this
earlier it suddenly makes it not seem
like YouTube yeah all right I want to
talk about irony and because a lot of
your videos deal with your first videos
about David Foster Wallace the problem
with irony but then a lot of your videos
are also about like Rick and Morty
Simpsons South Park all these shows
Bojack horseman that are largely the
capital I think they come from cynicism
irony all that all that stuff how do you
think about that and do you think that
there's any scaffold of meaning that
they're missing or do you think that
what do you think about these shows it's
a really really hard question because
even once you're teaching from that mode
of discourse like once you're teaching
from Arne and you are using it to pull
back the veil on things and say this is
not how it seems kind of right it's hard
to escape that it's hard to go back and
say now I'm only gonna talk about this
from this one level and and be confident
and sincere about that and I'm not gonna
talk about the potential underlayer that
subverts that yeah right it's a sword
that cuts both ways it cuts both ways I
mean I can't make the point any better
than losted however many years ago which
was just like once everything is
saturated with that where do you go from
there like once you've once you've
ironically deconstructed everything then
what like yeah like and you know we
talked about this just at lunch which
was that
like you can see these hyper sincere
figures coming into the mainstream
because there are a lot of people who
are lost because everything in their
generation has just been so taken apart
to the point where they're like what
should i what should I believe yeah and
then someone comes along and says here I
have one set of beliefs for you and and
and and I'm going to speak charismatic
alee and I have these ideas that are
appealing and here here's your framework
and then you see those people just
flying up and one of the big problems
with irony is you it's a great way to
you know show things for what they are
in some respects but again it doesn't
lead you necessarily to an answer which
is a big problem with irony yeah
in terms of the shows that you mentioned
though one of the things about them as I
think they know that like these these
writers know the about this problem and
so a lot of them have tried to add in
elements of the opposite of like how do
we sincerity at the end of the irony
right
yeah and like exactly which has been
called a lot of things yeah it gets most
popularly it's been called meta
modernism right it's very hard to define
easily but essentially like for example
Bojack horseman like he's so well
trained in the cynicism of the V like
just like the audience and the way to
pass through that is essentially to have
him say something ironic or cynical and
then have the opposite be true in the
narrative and and I think Raphael
bob-waksberg is a genius when it comes
to this which is sort of like I'm gonna
take something that everybody
is so ironic and cynical about and then
show that it it's not necessarily the
be-all end-all truth about the matter
and that it can also go the other
direction a lot of the time yeah
and so I think a lot of a lot of writers
know this problem they've been working
on it I think one of the big problems
remains is that irony makes the viewer
feel smarter than they are
it's true it's true it's just a fact is
like hahaha I'm in on the joke so and
and that keeps someone attached to it
right and and so when they when someone
watches Jon Stewart and he makes an
ironic comment this is old now he's not
on TV well like when they feel like
they're in on the joke boom you
activated the tribal senses that person
is ready to keep listening to them being
holier-than-thou
ironic above the other person it remains
a problem in culture I don't think it's
as bad as it was when Wallace was
talking about it at least I don't think
so like I think there's so many other
outlets now the internet that you don't
have to be stuck there sure I was
definitely stuck there which is why he's
so influential on me is like I thought
it was the be-all end-all I was raised
on Jon Stewart I was raised on simply
treating things as ironic constantly and
then all the sudden reading Wallace was
like it was almost like a flip switched
in my brain a switch flipped a switch
flipped the words yeah in my brain and
and all of a sudden I was like oh my
gosh like a weight has been lifted off
my shoulders you know what I mean yeah
yeah it's amazing that a writer can do
that for you but they can I think I
think most people on YouTube want to
encourage more creative content more you
lest Logan Paul I don't speak for
everybody obviously for but and more
will scoters oh that's how do i said how
do we make that happen too complimentary
I don't know the answer to that question
to be honest because there's only one
will Scouter yeah well but there's so
many other creative people there how do
we encourage quality content it it's
it's the media the medium is in charge
there is no thing that individuals
outside of being a creator and hoping
that you catch fire there's no other
enforcement systems so until there's a
system in place where people are
rewarded for high-quality creative
things they're not going to exist like
you know yes there are people who
operate outside of the economy and they
become really creative and they struggle
and they make cool things right but if
you want it to be widespread it has to
be a part of the economy so patreon is
getting there a simple thought
experiment for viewers would be if think
about how often you buy a coffee right
let's say your coffee is anywhere from a
dollar fifty to four dollars right
Starbucks or or your bodega down the
corner so if you put that same amount of
money a dollar toward all the people you
subscribe to that might be way to money
that might be $200 but let's say there's
two or three that you love the only way
you can change the economy in terms of
like without having YouTube change the
way ads work is to do it yourself as an
audience member yeah and say here
instead of buying a coffee every day
that comes out to like I don't know
anywhere from 32
one hundred and fifty dollars a month if
you really drink a lot of coffee what if
I just sequestered like five dollars for
a person for some people that's you
can't do that some people don't you keep
it as an audience member you don't have
that money but most people buy coffee
will a lot of people make purchases
unknowingly
and they just kind of throw the money
everywhere and I can tell you as someone
who has a patron that like mentally and
financially every dollar makes the
ability to be creative and higher
quality possible like without question
you know I think it was your movie sucks
who said that if one percent of my three
hundred thousand this was a long time
ago I think he's way bigger now but if
it was like one percent of my 300,000
subscribers gave me a dollar a month
that would change every time Joe yeah I
change everything and and those people
throwing that dollar out probably would
have no idea that they were you know
like missing that in their finances in a
bad way I guess that's not a good way to
put it one dollar is not that big of a
change in your daily financial activity
and it is collectively a huge deal for
us right it won't for most people that
won't change their standard of living
for them but given enough of them that
do it it will change the standard of
living for the greater and give them
more freedom to do it I think that's
interesting and I think people are
coming to around to the fact that the
new like patreon isn't going away and
the need for creators to make money
isn't going away and with everything
becoming free you don't really have to
have cable anymore you can like have
Netflix which is pretty cheap yet of all
these things which which are pretty
cheap so you're freed up in the side of
information and like entertainment have
become way cheaper but you also it's
gotten harder because of that before
creators I make money there's less money
for that so you
lot of time I don't know because it's
hard to make a call to action and say
like oh you should give money or
whatever but it really does make a
difference for the individual creator
and you can really foster some change
whereas before you were maybe supporting
a thousand channels that you know maybe
you only cared about like five of the
thousand package now you can directly
support with the money that you save
from like you're not paying for TV
anymore you can directly create more of
the content you want to see and you can
see more of that in the world yes I I
mean it's it's very it's it's not a
position that I can argue very
comfortably but like I do think that you
need to pay for content that comes out
you know like creators need to get paid
somehow and at the same time the culture
of like free remix everything is also
good so it's really hard to like find a
sweet spot where you're like content
creators need to get paid but also like
we should keep things free and open so
that more people can remix imminently so
I don't think we culturally have hit a
sweet spot yet in in terms of that I do
think more people are coming around to
the idea of I want to go out of my way
to support content yeah and so it so
back to the original premise of the
question which is how do we add more
high-quality creative people to make
youtube videos I don't I'm trash no you
heard it here first that YouTube yeah
and what I don't know last name it's one
of the two so it's either as an
individual you goes directly to creator
through patreon or something similar
yeah or the system in place changes the
way it treats creators but yeah thank
you that's very complimentary
yeah and I know I do I do appreciate
that like but that's that's really how I
feel about your content thanks I mean
yeah there are very few creators with
you included but every now and then like
someone will release a video and it's
like just I'll stop whatever I'm doing
and I have to go watch it so I like that
yeah but it's like I see that comment a
lot actually from people there's like
you know coffee break uploads no problem
and watch that video
yeah that's but it's nice yeah
but anyways yeah it's a kind of I mean
kind of wrap up yeah thanks for coming
on the show this is the first iteration
of the coffee with podcasts slash video
so yeah forgive my editing mistakes or
they're all mine yeah 3,000 ceramic pots
man you'll get there
yeah yeah ventually no I this is great
thank you for starting this I think it's
a really good idea and I hope that you
continue to do this with a lot of other
interesting people because there are an
infinity of interesting people making
content out there so I think you have a
great group of people to draw from and I
think this is a great idea
thanks yeah man we'll see thanks for
being the first one yeah I'll maybe
bring you on again when we get this
thing figured out and we'll have like a
really shoot of that well we could have
yet episodes coder when it hits 2
million subs yeah one day oh that's what
you gonna be saying on like year yeah
25th video
[Laughter]
slowly log last ones like they think
you've retired and like 25 years later
you're like 80 you released your final
yeah it took me 10 years to make this
last video increasingly it takes me
increasingly longer to make videos which
is the opposite direction of everybody
else that would be that would be very
fast right all right well thank you yeah
and got in this great let's just wrap it
up man quote from the world according to
Mister Rogers
[Music]
in times of stress the best thing we can
do for each other is to listen with our
ears and our hearts and to be assured
that our questions are just as important
as our answers